new card what do you think when there
still was the Wall Street uh trading
floors and everything I went and visited
you know all different levels of people
at Wall Street but the guys on the
trading floor when I arrived there
before making the film and a bunch of
them they were going oh Patrick Bateman
and Pat me on the back and go oh yeah we
love him and I was like yeah ironically
right and they were like what do you
mean so it was always worrying in many
ways in the same way that people were
telling me hey you can't go play Patrick
Bateman it's career suicide and I was
like bring it on other people also said
hey you know if you play Batman that's
it you're never going to play anything
else again you will always be Batman and
I won't bring it on don't I look okay
I'd come off of making a couple of films
that I've been less than satisfied with
and just really wanted something where I
could become immersed and obsessed with
it you know I mean I remember at the
time it was like not the smart thing to
do blue but I've never been Smart in a
business way but it was something that I
really wanted to challenge myself and
kind of see could I achieve that could I
fulfill how I imagined that the part of
Trevor should be played